>>> OFFICIALS IN HAWAII ARE
WARNING THAT LAVA -- ARE WARNING
RESIDENTS,S LAVA FLOWING FROM
THE WORLD'S LARGEST ACTIVE
VOLCANO.
IT'S NOW JUST A FEW MILES FROM
THE BIG ISLAND'S MAIN HIGHWAY.
THE VOLCANO ERUPTING FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN DECADES.
LOOK AT THE BEAUTIFUL,
AWE-INSPIRING IMAGES, AS A
NEIGHBORING VOLCANO CONTINUES TO
ERUPT.
THE DUAL ERUPTION CAUSING
EXCITEMENT, BUT ALSO,
UNDERSTANDABLY, SOME CONCERNS.
JOINING ME IS HAWAII'S GOVERNOR.
YOU ISSUED AN EMERGENCY ORDER
THIS WEEK REGARDING THE
ERUPTION.
WHAT DOES THAT ALLOW YOU TO DO?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
THE EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION
ALLOWS US TO BE PROACTIVE.
WE WOULD MAKE AVAILABLE ALL THE
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS SHOULD IT
BE NECESSARY TO ACTIVATE THE
NATIONAL GUARD, TO HELP WITH
CONTROL, KEEP PEOPLE AWAY FROM
THE VOLCANO, OR SHOULD
EVACUATIONS BE NECESSARY, THAT
WOULD JUST ALLOW US TO ACT
QUICKLY AND PROMPTLY.
>> WHICH OBVIOUSLY IS PONT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A VOLCANIC
ERUPTION.
WE'RE SHOWING OUR VIEWERS THE
BEAUTIFUL, STUNLE IMAGES FROM
THE FLOWS.
A VOLCANIC ERUPTION IS AT THE
SAME TIME STUNNING, EXCITING,
BUT ALSO OBVIOUSLY DANGEROUS.
WHAT ARE YOUR PRIORITIES RIGHT
NOW?
WHAT ARE YOU MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT?
>> CERTAINLY WE CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE AIR QUALITY AROUND
THE ERUPTION.
WE HAVE A SERIES OF AIR QUALITY
MONITORS AROUND THE ISLAND AND A
WEBSITE THAT PROVIDES UP-TO-DATE
INFORMATION.
YOU KNOW, THE CONCERN ABOUT
ABOUT DANGEROUS GASES FROM THE
FITS YOUR.
THE MOST DANGEROUS IS SULFUR
DIOXIDE.
WE ENCOURAGE VISITORS TO
CONTINUE TO COME.
IT'S SAFE TO VISIT THE ISLAND,
BUT CERTAINLY OBSERVING THE
VOLCANO SHOULD OCCUR AT A
DISTANCE.
IT'S NOT SAFE TO GET UP CLOSE.
>> THE U.S. GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
SAYS IT'S ABOUT 4 1/2 MILES AWAY
FROM THE MAIN HIGHWAY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THAT?
>> CERTAIN WE ARE MONITORING THE
FLOW MULTITAL TIMES A DAY TO
KEEP TRACK OF IT.
IT'S STILL A WAYS AWAY, BUT THAT
IS THE MAIN HIGHWAY.
AND SO WE ARE WATCHING THAT
CAREFULLY.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE CONCERNED,
BECAUSE VISITORS AND RESIDENTS
ARE STOPPING ALONG THE HIGHWAY,
AND SOMETIMES DRIVERS ARE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION FULLY.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT TRAFFIC
CONTROL ON THE HINT, BUT IT'S
STILL A WAYS AWAY, BUT WE'LL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND WATCH
IT.
>> FINALLY, YOU TOUCHED ON THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HOLIDAY PLANS -- LUCKY ENOUGH TO
HAVE HOLIDAY PLANS TO COME VISIT
HAWAII.
WHAT SHOULD PEOPLE DO?
SHOULD THEY STILL COME?
>> CERTAINLY.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE EVERYONE WHO
HAS PLANS TO VISIT THE ISLAND TO
CONTINUE.
IT IS COMPLETELY SAFE.
THE ERUPTION SITE IS HIGH UP THE
MOUNTAIN, AND IT'S IN A
RELATIVELY ISOLATED LOCATION.
IT IS SAFE TO VIEW THE VOLCANO.
AS YOU SAID, IT IS A SPECTACULAR
FROM AFAR.
SO, CERTAINLY, WE ENCOURAGE
THOSE WHO HAVE PLANS TO CONTINUE
TO COME.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THEM VISIT
HERE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU, GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.